chaque année 80 mille festivaliers
débarque à cannes pour la grande fête du
cinéma à côté des professionnels du
milieu ce sont ceux aussi en devenir des
étudiants à qui viennent pour la plupart
à leur premier festival et victoria
roblin et nicolas rodriguez sont de 3
yes l'institut de l'image et du son est
d'elancourt ils ont inscrit leur court
métrage le temps d'un regard dans un
espace dédié le short film corner
[Musique]
victoria nicolas avant de parler du
court métrage le temps d'un regard
pendant votre présence ici à cannes pour
des étudiants en cinéma qui viennent de
terminer leur cursus qu'est le qu'est ce
que ça représente d'être ici pour vous
alors pour nous c'est très important
d'être ici parce que c'est parce qu'on
désire rencontrer beaucoup de monde et
rencontrer du monde
notamment pour faire parler un peu de
notre de notre court métrage et se faire
des nouvelles relations pour des projets
à venir se cultiver aussi un peu
lorsqu'il ya une énorme diversité de
films de jean donc voilà il ya plein de
films hyper intéressant à découvrir
qu'on n'aurait pas forcément l'occasion
de découvrir découvrir ailleurs et voilà
et participer aux soirées après pour
rencontrer des gens et discuter un peu
tout ça et quand on est dans le monde du
cinéma c'est le lieu où il faut être
cannes c'est important d'être ici
surtout pour nous disons que comme on
n'a pas de connaissances dans le cinéma
mine de rien cannes pendant quinze jours
c'est quand même une réunion de
professionnels ou même avec des rendez
vous pendant un an à paris on
on n'arriverait pas rencontré autant de
gens donc on va dans des soirées on
rencontre des professionnels
si on est au bon endroit au bon moment
qu'on a le bon scénario on peut avoir
une opportunité que ailleurs on n'aurait
pas alors vous avez inscrit six au short
film corner le court métrage le temps
d'un regard ça parle de quoi
le temps ailleurs alors le temps d'un
regard c'est une passion amoureuse
lilien en fait croiser son ex et le
temps d'un regard elle vit un souvenir
où elle ce soin de leurs moments forts
de la relation donc nous en fait on a
souhaité parler d'une passion amoureuse
parce que à part quelques films où j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment crédible comme un
vieux film je sais pas si vous
connaissez césar et rosalie voilà ou
même l'offre de gaspar noé je trouve que
leur passion amoureux sont crédibles à
l'écran et c'est ça que je trouve qu'il
manque un petit peu donc on a essayé de
faire la même chose avec un genre un peu
plus particulier voilà dernière question
le temps d'un regard est inscrit ici
c'est un court métrage qui a déjà été
récompensé et qui est sélectionné dans
d'autres festivals c'est ça alors depuis
quelques mois on l'inscrit à plusieurs
festivals en france et dans le monde
entier finalement il a été récompensé
le prix de la photographie au cinéma
tort donc un festival français et il a
été sélectionné au toronto film festival
et aux films et aux los angeles film
festival aussi merci dorian nicolas
merci à vous
[Musique]
comme chaque jour zoom sur un film
financé par la région ile-de-france le
silencio ce de béatrice seigner est
sélectionné à cannes au sein de la
quinzaine des réalisateurs
il met en lumière une famille qui a fui
le conflit armé en colombie dans lequel
a disparu le père elle trouve refuge sur
une petite île au milieu de l'amazonie
mais découvre très vite que lille est
habitée par des fantômes
l'asam lèvres
quel dans le bagne allemand
pas
c'est la fin de cannes 78 retour dès
demain pour faire connaissance avec
d'autres yvelinois du festival
[Musique]